[Music]
[Music]
Alan Brody I'm the associate provost for
the Arts at MIT and I want to welcome
the MIT community and everyone else as
well to this 2004 Abramowitz lecture
with Margaret Atwood we're just thrilled
to have you here and we're certainly
thrilled to have Margaret here as well
before I begin let me just say unless
you are a drug dealer or an obstetrician
please turn off your cell phones pagers
the Abramowitz lecture series was
established at MIT through the
generosity and imagination of William L
Abramowitz class of 35 as a memorial to
his father it's been sustained since his
death by the devoted interest of his
wife and children
and we lost Lee his wife this year she
was an extraordinary woman dedicated to
this lecture series dedicated to MIT to
the memory of William and was was
consistently right up until the end
interested in this series and sensitive
and excited about the kinds of things
we've been doing and I personally I'm
going to miss her a great deal since
1961 the Abramowitz series has brought
renowned performing artists and writers
to MIT to perform present public
lectures and always to collaborate with
students and faculty in free programs is
Dan Epstein here there is I believe
there's a member of the Abramowitz
family that we'd like to thank but he
didn't he didn't make it so much for
commitment
okay if you're in the overflow room
thanks so much
I want I want to introduce Candace
Callison who was on the Abramowitz
selection committee she's a PhD
candidate now in STS and she is
personally responsible for bringing
Margaret here by delivering a
hand-delivered note to her at the Giller
Awards so Candace you'll speak about
Margaret
at least say Canada is a small town but
I was really surprised there's only two
degrees of separation between myself and
our esteemed guest today it's my great
privilege to introduce Margaret Atwood
to you as many of you well know she is
the prolific author of sixteen works of
fiction five collections of nonfiction
fifteen editions of poetry and four
children's books and those are just the
major publishers titles her work has
went a long list of honours including
the Booker Prize and the Giller Prize
Canada's top literary award I grew up in
Canada and I have to say that the name
Margaret Atwood is and was synonymous
with everything that is great about
Canadian fiction and indeed what puts
Canada on the map in the literary world
but during the mid-90s I began to
understand her as a writer who was at
work both in the so-called real world
and in the fictive world she was
creating at that time as a member and
past president of pan Canada she spoke
out on behalf of Ken Serra
a Nigerian writer who faced execution
for his writing and political action in
his own country
I remember hearing on the radio that
even Margaret Atwood had spoken out in
support of this writer who was
previously an obscure figure to me and
much of the Canadian public it was a cue
that we had better sit up and take
notice of what was happening on the
other side of the world similarly as the
past couple years of seen America go to
war in Iraq and Afghanistan her voice
could be found in newspapers and
publications like the nation calling
readers to think and act about the
events taking place here and on the
other side of the globe perhaps this is
why nestled in amongst her list of
prizes for literature and writing are
awards that speak on both her effect on
an involvement with the non fictive
world awards like ms magazines Woman of
the Year humanist of the year and the
Order of Canada Canada's top honor to
those who have immeasurably contributed
to our society as I was preparing to
introduce her today I went online and
read mem the many rave reviews for Oryx
and Crake and in amongst them on a
message board
I found a posting from an individual
with a summary line shockingly relevant
this perhaps sums up her work in general
and specifically in regards to Oryx and
Crake
the posting went on to praise this novel
for the creation of an all too
recognizable world in which characters
grapple with moral and scientific
dilemmas again it seems that it is a cue
to sit up and start thinking with and
through science and technology about the
world we are collectively creating and
perhaps there is no better crowd that
ours at MIT that understands the
relevancy of thinking about society
through this sort of lens so without
further ado here to talk more about her
work and her latest novel Margaret
Atwood
thank you very much it's a great
pleasure to be here today I have been at
MIT before as I recall that event took
place in a corridor and I'm glad we all
have chairs today I'm here to talk about
my novel called Oryx and Crake but
before I do that I'll give you a little
bit of background because people are
asking me things like how did you did
the research and why were you interested
in this subject and so forth it is a
book about that wonderful place called
the future which we can invent because
none of us have ever been there and come
back yet and I think the future was what
we took to and we no longer sent
fictional characters to place like
places like hell now we've got the
future for a while we sent them to
uninhabited islands but we ran out of
those and sometimes we send them to
other universes but I'm I can't do other
universes so it's this universe a little
bit further on and as for The Handmaid's
Tale I put nothing in it that does not
have its corresponding clipping in the
ominous brown research books in the
cellar that is nothing is absolutely
pure invention although I have to admit
I cranked a few things up a bit
however they the spider goat is with us
today and so is the luminous green
rabbit
I will not here gusts of shock from this
crowd because you already know that but
some people go oh no anyway I in fact
grew up amongst the scientists my father
was a biologist he was an entomologist
these are noteworthy for producing weird
writer offspring
and date a lot of biologists write
themselves and a lot of them actually
read and my dad was a great reader he
loved history he loved fiction and he
was known to burst into Long snatches of
memorized Sir Walter Scott poems and
also to give us quizzes on Sherlock
Holmes as in what Sherlock Holmes story
contains the bell pole and the snake
right so that's how I grew up and I
thought I was going to be a biologist I
was headed in that direction my brother
actually became one he became a marine
biologist and from there he went into
neuroscience and now he's pretty much
with the synapse and when I published my
first book of poetry he wrote me a
congratulatory letter that said
congratulations on publishing your first
book of poetry I used to do that kind of
thing myself when I was younger so I've
always kept up with the pop science
reading and by pop science reading I
mean the kind where you don't have to do
the math here itself and like other
people to do the math and then tell me
what they've found out but I think that
growing up with the scientists gives you
a couple of things number one you're
very observant you observe details it's
not just a tree it's a certain kind of
tree and it also makes you quite
skeptical I don't mean that you're a
cynic or a pessimist I mean that you
question things because as you know in
science an experiment has to be
repeatable and get the same results so
you are always asking things like well
how did they come to that conclusion how
did they do the experiment and since I
spent some time in market research as
well I
the same skepticism about polls I want
to know what the question was and also
what the question was that was asked
just before that question because that
can skew the results as well Oryx and
Crake its structure is like that of the
Iliad a book it resembles and no other
way but that is it begins in the middle
of events and then we go back in time to
find out how we got to that midpoint and
then we go forward in time to find out
what the protagonist will do next
and at the midpoint of the story the
protagonist who began life as a boy
called Jimmy has changed his name to
snowmen that is not as in Frost either
but as in the abominable snowman
creature that may or may not exist and
may or may not be semi human which is
kind of the way he's feeling about
himself when the story opens he's living
in a tree where he sleeps at night this
is because of the new and unusual
life-forms that are running around on
the ground at night and you'll be happy
to know that I've provided him with
doctor tape
there will be duct tape in the future is
with the aid of this duct tape that he
has constructed the platform on which he
spends his nights he kinds of he kind of
wishes he might be able to have a fire
up there but he can't and apart from the
duct tape he's not really a handy kind
of guy he's not a kind of Boy Scout sort
of person he is therefore unable to dig
the hole in the ground with the pointed
stake on which to impale small-game he
can't do that but he is able to wield a
can opener this is a skill I would
advise everyone to acquire with the aid
of this can opener he has been opening
cans that he has found left around and
he has been eating the contents because
there are no other people as such in his
vicinity something has happened to them
we find out in the course of the plot
what but I would never think of blowing
it for you because shocking as it may
seem seem to me some of you may not yet
have read this but there are however
some people like creatures living nearby
along with the luminous rabbits
we've got the luminous rabbits already
by the way and and some other animals
that have been invented but these new
people have been improved and I'll tell
you some of the improvements I think
some of them would be quite good thus
disproving the question surely or
against science no I think it's great as
long as it used for is for for improving
types of things for instance these
people have built-in sunblock I think
that would be good
that means they don't need the textile
industry or vogue magazine or shopping
they don't need any of those things
because they don't have any clothes they
have an extra layer of skin on the
bottoms of their feet giving them a kind
of Birkenstock effect and they have
built-in mosquito repellent which I
think would also be a major plus they do
smell like walking citrus fruits but
that wouldn't be too bad in addition to
that they're not only vegetarian better
they will never need agriculture because
they can eat leaves unlike you and me we
can't digest them but these people can
and grass as well
this means that their digestive systems
would have to have been modified now
there are two possible models one would
have been the cow but that would have
had a less aesthetically pleasing effect
and these people are very good-looking
so instead they've been modified in the
direction of the rabbit if you saw thee
i think a few months ago National
Geographic with the new big wheel of
life about his related to whom you will
have noted that we are more closely
related to the rabbit than previously
thought
so maybe it wouldn't be too hard now
there are some side effects to having
the digestive system of a rabbit and you
will come across those in the book but
it's a small price to pay
the other modification they have which I
think would be very useful is that they
can purr the purring is not to make them
cuter there is in fact grounds to
believe I did say I cranked some things
up a bit but there's there's grounds to
believe that the purring of the cat has
a couple of functions we we know that
cats purr when they're happy but we also
know that they've hurt when they're in
pain and if you have ever had a cat you
will know that if you have been injured
or ill your cat is very likely to get up
on top of you and pur over your injured
part or indeed over your whole self if
you've got something like the flu and
you will also know that if a person
walks into your house who hates and
fears cats your cat will go immediately
to that person so possibly the purring
is a self-healing aid and your cat is
going over to that person out of the
desire to be helpful and kind they're
the only altruistic thing account has
ever been known to do so the people in
this book have got purring because they
don't have band-aids or any other they
don't have hospitals but they do have
purring so they can purr to self-heal
but the very very very best thing of all
that they have and I think this would be
such an improvement
instead of being intermittently
monogamous the way we are they are
instead seasonal like most other animals
so they're either in season in which
case they're interested or they're not
in season in which case they're not and
to make things even more clear they like
many another animal are color-coded so
that when they're in season parts of
them turned blue think how useful that
would be no more no means no no means
yes no more I'm washing my hair and I'll
also be washing my hair next Friday
no more unrequited love no more pain and
anguish over this issue
you're either in season or you're not in
season and no more by the way pair
blending so so there they are
they will never write Othello in fact
they will never write anything because
they can't write these people live at
some distance from our protagonist why
is that first of all to them he looks
pretty strange and monstrous but also
for him they're pretty boring so he
actually doesn't want to spend too much
time with them because they don't
understand him at all and they don't
share many of the same items of interest
this is his predicament at the beginning
of the book the two characters on the
front Oryx who was a female person and
Crake who was a male person are dead by
the time the book begins I think this is
a great advantage what it means is that
we see them only through Jimmy snowmen
and his memories of them they happen to
have been the two most important people
in his life
Oryx was the person he loved and
idealized he's quite a romantic ever
since he first saw her on an internet
porn site and Craig as his best friend
with whom he went to high school now at
the end of high school their paths
diverged for a while because Jimmy was
not a numbers person Jimmy was a words
person Craig on the other hand was good
at both so Craig got to go off to the
very well-funded
Watson Crick Institute and Jimmy was
stuck with the crumbling falling apart
Martha Graham Academy the graduates of
which are all going to end up in
advertising in the future because in the
future the arts have somewhat diminished
there is for instance no longer quite
the film industry there is now because
people can make their own films
digitally on their very own computers
and Jimmy himself has made a quite an
effect of naked Pride and Prejudice so
to sum it up it's a joke filled fun
packed rollicking adventure adventure
story about the downfall of the human
race not everybody can get those two
ideas together in their heads but I
think it's a cheering sort of book much
in the same way that a Christmas carol
is cheering because Scrooge gets to wake
up at the end and he gets to say it was
all a horrible dream I'm not really dead
and I've got a second chance and you can
wake up at the end of the book and say
it's only a book we're on the way
true but we do still have time and we've
got a second chance and the other reason
it's cheering is that however awful
things may be in your life they're much
worse in the book
I always preferred that kind of book I
don't like books at all in which
everybody's happy all the time they they
depress me no end this is the only book
that has ever received a fan letter from
Kermit the Frog
Kermit sent the fan letter it's got his
picture on it and he also sent a poem
right on the fan letter and the poem
says Oryx and Crake Oryx and Crake a
frog by a lake
reading Oryx and Crake no I do not lie
this is true I'll tell you why I got
this van letter the person who edits the
Sunday Times sorry
yes Sunday Times Literary section in
London England is a person called Erica
Wagner Erica Wagner grew up in New York
and her first job at the age of 8 was
forging the signature of Kermit the Frog
on all of Kermit's answers to fan
letters because her parents job was
answering all of the Muppet fan mail
this is a true story so I think we've
got I think we put that fan letter on
our website I'm going to read you a tiny
bit out of the book it's not the bit I
usually choose to read but for you I'll
read it and it might help explain why
Kermit was so taken with this book it's
a conversation between Craig as a
teenager and Jimmy as now I guess
they're both in there they're both in
their early 20s and they've got together
although they're at different colleges
how much misery crakes had one lunch
time how much needless despair has been
caused by a series of biological
mismatches
a misalignment of the hormones and
pheromones resulting in the fact that
the one you love so passionately won't
or can't love you as a species were
pathetic in that way imperfectly
monogamous if we could only pair bond
for life like Gibbons or else
opt for total guilt-free promiscuity
there'd be no more sexual torment better
plan
make it cyclically and also inevitable
as in the other mammals you'd never want
someone you couldn't have true enough
Jimmy replied or Jim as he was now
insisting without results everyone still
called him Jimmy but think what we'd be
giving up such as courtship behavior in
your plan we'd just be a bunch of
hormone robots Jimmy thought he should
put things in crates terms which was why
he said courtship behavior what he meant
was the challenge the excitement the
chase there'd be no free choice
there's courtship behavior and my plan
said Craig except that it would always
succeed and where hormone Rob robots
anyway only were faulty ones well what
about art said Jimmy a little
desperately he was after all a student
at the Martha Graham Academy so he cell
felt some need to defend the art and
creativity turf what about it said Craig
smiling his calm smile all that
mismatching you talk about it's been an
inspiration or that's what they say
think of all the poetry think Petrarch
think john dunn think the vita nuova
think art said craig i guess they still
do a lot of jabbering about that over
where you are
what is it Byron said who'd write if
they could do otherwise
something like that that's what I mean
said Jimmy he was alarmed by the
reference to Byron what right had crate
to poach on his own
a threadbare territory great should
stick to science and leave poor Byron to
Jimmy what do you mean said Craig as if
coaching a stutterer I mean when you
can't get the otherwise then wouldn't
you rather be [ __ ] sand craic
he wasn't including himself in this
question his tone was one of detached
but not very strong interest as if he
were conducting a survey of people's
less attractive personal habits such as
nose picking Jimmy found that his face
got red err and his voice got squeakier
the more outrageous Craig became he
hated that when any civilization is dust
and ashes he said artists all that's
left over images words music imaginative
structures meaning human meaning that is
as defined by them you have to admit
that that's not quite all that's left
over said Craig the archaeologists are
just as interested in nod bones and old
bricks and ossified [ __ ] these days
sometimes more interested they think
human meaning is defined by those things
too Jimmy would like to have said why
are you always putting me down but he
was afraid of the possible answers
because it's so easy being one of them
so one study said what have you got
against it against what art nothing said
Craig lazily people could amuse
themselves any way they like if they
want to play with themselves in public
whack off over doodling scribbling and
fiddling it's fine with me anyway it
serves a biological purpose such as
Jimmy knew that everything depended on
keeping his cool these arguments had to
be played through like a game if he lost
his temper Craig won the mail frog in
mating season said Craig makes as much
noise as it can the females are
attracted to the male frog with the
biggest deepest voice because it
suggests a more powerful frog one with
superior genes
small male frogs it's been documented
discovered that if they position
themselves in empty drain pipes the pipe
acts as a voice amplifier and the small
frog up here is much larger than it
really is so so that's what art is for
the artist said Craig an empty drain
pipe an amplifier a stab at getting laid
your analogy falls down when it comes to
female artists said Jimmy they're not in
it to get laid
they've gained no biological advantage
from amplifying themselves since
potential mates would be deterred rather
than attracted by that sort of
amplification men aren't frogs they
don't want women who are ten times
bigger than them female artists are
biologically confused said Craig you
must have discovered that by now this
was a snide dig at Jimmy's current
snarled romance with a brunette poet who
renamed herself Morgana and recipients
to tell him what her given name had been
and he was currently on a 28-day sex
fast in honor of the great moon goddess
estra patroness of soybeans and bunnies
Martha Graham attracted those kinds of
girls an error though to have confided
this affair to to Craig
that's from Craig's post I'll read you a
small bit from his present and then we
can have a question-and-answer session
in which you can ask me things you are
dying to know such as how come you're a
blonde now so this is from Jimmy is
Jimmy snowman is wearing his bed sheet
and sitting on the beach and it's dusk
and he's remembering that little poem he
was taught as a child
snowman screws his eyes shut
pushes his fists into them clenches his
entire face
there is the Wishing Star all right it's
blue I wish I may I wish I might he says
have the wish I wish tonight that chance
Oh snowman why are you talking to no one
says voice snowman opens his eyes three
of the older children are standing just
out of reach regarding him with interest
they must have crept up on him in the
dusk I'm talking to Craig he says but
you talked to Craig through your shiny
thing is it broken
snowman lifts his left arm holds out his
watch this is for listening to crank
talking to him is different why are you
talking to him about stars
what are you telling to Craig Oh snowmen
I was telling him so snowman that you
ask too many questions he holds his
watch to his ear and he's telling me
that if you don't stop doing that you'll
be toast please o snowmen what is toast
another error snowman thinks he should
avoid arcane metaphors
towstee says is something very very bad
it's so bad I can't even describe it
now it's your bedtime go away what is
toast says snowman to himself once
they've run off toast is when you take a
piece of bread what is bread bread is
when you take some flour
what is flour we'll skip that part it's
too complicated bread is something you
can eat
made from a ground-up plant and shaped
like a stone you cook it please
why do you cook it why don't you just
eat the plant nevermind that part pay
attention you cook it and then you cut
it into slices and you put a slice into
a toaster which is a metal box that
heats up with electricity what is
electricity don't worry about that while
the slice is in the toaster you get out
the butter butter is a yellow grease
made from the mammary glands of skip the
butter so the toaster turns the slice of
bread black on both sides with smoke
coming out and then this toaster shoots
the slice up into the air and it falls
onto the floor
forget it says no man let's try again
toast was a pointless invention from the
dark ages toast was an implement of
torture that caused all those subjected
to it to regurgitate in verbal form the
sins and crimes of their past lives
toast was a ritual item devoured by
fetishists in the belief that it would
enhance their kinetic and sexual powers
toast cannot be explained by any
rational means
toast is me I am toast
we can do questions by you waving your
arm around and then I'll repeat it into
the mic so people will know what you
asked which will also give me a chance
to reformulate the question started
haunting me in another way but we even
to which future do you think is more
likely right now
all right the question was there is
another novel called The Handmaid's Tale
which was published in 1995 in which
projects a future in which the United
States of America has become a
totalitarian theocracy and for that and
that book came out of my interest in
world history American history clothing
laws and and such things and also my
irritation when people say it can't
happen here you know that always annoys
me very much because anything given the
right circumstances can happen anywhere
what are the circumstances under which
totalitarianism is usually come in
social disruption often connected with
economic disruption and fear so that
people are frightened and confused and
they are at a point where they're
willing to trade their freedoms for
something they think will be safety and
security so that is one possible form of
frightening future and my rule for that
book was I put nothing into it than
human beings hadn't already done at some
time or another so we know that this is
behavior that we are capable of and I
also am one of those people who believe
that you should listen to what people
say they're going to do if they get into
power because they probably will do it
okay
one of the mistakes with Hitler was that
people read Mein Kampf and they thought
oh he's just fooling wrong so I was born
in 1939 the Air Canada went into World
War two so I've always been interested
in those kinds of
of histories that's one kind of a
frightening future and I did set it in
Cambridge Massachusetts which annoyed
Harvard at the time but that would be
the right place to set such a book
because it can't happen here should be
placed in the most extreme here they
were I think somewhat perturbed that the
Widener Library became the home of the
Secret Service myth they didn't think it
was funny oh well one of my friends
wrote me a letter and said doesn't
anybody figured out yet that this book
is about the Harvard English department
which has changed its ways since but at
that time it didn't hire women I'm
really old so okay between that and this
book well what is more frightening I
would say that this book is more
frightening because when you're talking
about political systems we know that
they can be overcome and changed and
that's how the Handmaid's Tale ends it
ends with a section that takes place
after the time of the book in which that
thought system is over and I am
therefore one of those people who have
always thought that George Orwell's 1984
is a more cheerful book than some people
have supposed because what you remember
is the end of it with Winston Smith and
a comatose state and the boat grinding
into the human face forever but how the
book really ends is with a note on news
speak written in standard English in the
past tense which means that the world of
1984 has been finished okay so the that
is a more hopeful scenario the one in
this book brings together environmental
catastrophe which we're all ready excuse
me heading towards know what senile yet
can still open bottle of water cheering
it brings together environmental
catastrophe on the one hand and our our
scrabbling attempts to do something
about the diminishing food supply on the
other we went we are due to peak at nine
or 10 billion and in 2050 we have run
through the 90% of the world's fish
docks in the past 50 years
that's why Jimmy in the cafeteria has
fish finger 20% real fish I'm now
thinking that 20% was high interesting
question what is the other 80% so those
things are on the road and I think we're
past the point where even governments
can can be global warming deniers as
they have managed to do so well for so
many years so I'd say this one is
scarier although it's not completely
game over for the human race even in
this book as we discover with mixed
feelings towards the end
yes how do I say the crackers evolving
well their creator has tried very hard
to get rid of a few things in them
without success for instance they still
are avid question askers someone has to
find him and beings as the animal that
asks why so they still do that he's
tried to get rid of singing but he
couldn't do that either music I think it
seems to be quite hardwired and he's
tried to get rid of dreams and he
couldn't do that so they still make
music have dreams and ask questions
where will that lead I certainly
wouldn't want to narrow the
possibilities by giving my own opinion
let us say that they do start making
something suspiciously something
suspicious towards the end of the book
yes what it was like for a new writer
writing my first novel and becoming
published I started writing when I was
16 in high school because I knew no
better and
I did not know actually how hard it was
going to be
I was quite sanguine about the whole
thing
I actually thought and this is true I
thought I could write true romance
stories in the day because you could
make money out of those and I would sell
those and then in the evenings I would
write my works of blazing artistic
genius and I did try a couple of those
two romance stories but I could not do
them not because of the plots I was good
at the plots I know what the basic plot
is it was in those days girl meets two
boys one of them works in a shoe store
the other has a motorcycle
jingis tangled up with the one with the
motorcycle and they have an episode on
the sofa and in those days it had to be
phrased as such and then they were one
dot dot dot dot well that was the part I
couldn't do I couldn't do the dots after
that he writes off on his motorcycle and
she has remorse and if the story has a
happy ending she marries the guy from
the shoe store who forgives her for
everything or else just isn't told so I
could do those ok that so that wasn't
going to work out so I was going to be a
journalist
my parents bit their tongues they had
foreseen a wonderful career in botany
for me because I was quite good at it
and if I had gone in that direction I
would be cloning you're a
glow-in-the-dark potatoes right now so
they dredged up some second cousin who
told me at that time the 50s if you
become a woman journalist and worked for
a newspaper you will only write two
things the wedding write-ups and the
obituaries good training for a novelist
anyway but so I went I went into Honors
English instead that way I could teach
at a university and then in the summers
I could write my towering works of
blazing artistic
so I did take two years off in the
middle because I was scared of my Latin
exam at Harvard and I worked in a market
research company lived in a closet and
it was in a rooming house they had those
then and I wrote my first novel which
was rejected by everyone I also wrote a
book of poems and this is worse it was
accepted I told all my friends and then
by the third member of the small
literary press it was rejected how
depressing is not what did i do I got
engaged well who can blame me after that
I was gonna run off to Europe live in a
garret wear black clothing drink
absinthe smoke cigarettes write towering
works of blazing artistic genius while
working as a waitress in the day times
that plan came to nothing first of all I
couldn't do the smoking it made me cough
I couldn't do the drinking it made me
throw up
I have New England Puritan ancestors so
hits genetic so I went to graduate
school
[Applause]
that way I could well you know the story
so then I got a teaching job at
University of British Columbia and what
did I teach I was at the lowest rung I
taught grammar to engineering students
[Laughter]
at 8:30 in the morning in a Quonset hut
I had those Quonset huts left over from
World War two we were all asleep so it
was okay but I did quite a good thing
for them
I made them read the parables of Kafka
useful to them in their future work and
write short prose pieces based on those
which they quite like doing because they
had a puzzle element and then we could
work on the grammar that way and I also
taught the Whistlestop chorus Chaucer
did TS Eliot like that and while I was
there I wrote my first published novel
not the one that was rejected it was
good it was rejected it wasn't a very
good novel the edible woman and I wrote
it on UBC exam booklets which have a
handy lined page down the right-hand in
that a place where you can do the
doodling on the left so those were the
days before computers I then typed all
of this onto my typewriter with my
typewriter on two pieces of paper I've
never been able to type I'm so glad they
invented computers because I no longer
have to use the little white bottle with
the brush the little white lines that
you can type and stick on all of that is
gone now I have the cheerful man in the
box who
waives it me all I need if I'm feeling
lonely all I need to do is pretend I'm
writing a letter would you like some
help I can't get Bob the paperclip on my
computer but I've been told about him
anyway so that's what I did I typed it
all up and then I I sent it in to the
publisher he lost it this is a Canadian
story I actually got an acceptance
letter and then I heard nothing but I
was studying for my orals and I knew
nothing about publishing anyway so I
didn't know why it was taking so long
and by the time I came out of my trance
my orals trance I wrote them a letter by
that time I published a book of poetry
and won a major literary award and I
said where is my novel then I got a
letter from them saying we read
something in the paper about your major
literary prize and it says you've
written a novel could we see it then the
publisher took me out and had a drink he
had actually five drinks and he told me
the most outrageous lie he had never
been able to get away with us now but
what he told me was that the manuscript
had been in the hands of a woman editor
who had gotten pregnant and you know how
that makes them go funny in the head and
she had left it in a drawer without
telling anyone and that's why they
hadn't been answering my letters what a
whopper it was all the time on his very
own floor covered up with other
manuscripts so that's my publishing
story about my first novel which came
out in 1969 although I had written it in
sixty four or five and I did my very
very first book signing in
men's sock and underwear Department of
the Hudson's Bay Company in Edmonton
Alberta there I was with yes I don't
know why that happened
it was the publicist first week on the
job doing do we know how long she lasted
after that actually no but there I was
with my little pile of books saying the
Edible woman near are these guys coming
in and their galoshes because it was
winter looking to snaffle a pair of
jockey shorts during their lunch hour
and they took one look at me and ran the
other way I think I sold two copies and
I thought is this the glamorous literary
life well it did get more glamorous
after that I can't remember when that
was anything else who'd like to know
[Music]
don't throw anything out you never know
when it might come in handy
how many too many scripts did I submit
before I finally got one published I
used to submit a book of poems a year
and that went on for some time so I
think probably came out it is the word
of encouragement you're looking for as
for the writing part don't look down
just pretend you're crossing Niagara on
a tightrope
don't look down it's one step ahead one
foot in front of the other don't worry
about large issues worry about the page
the page is all you've got yes
[Music]
yes closure is very useful in some kinds
of writing detective stories you would
feel very ticked off you read through
the whole thing and there was no answer
you know you'd really feel annoyed
because that's the kind of book you want
to read you want to read one with
closure which things get wrapped up at
the end I would like to write that kind
of book but I don't and I think I'd like
to leave a space at the end so that the
reader can because I think that reading
is a very participatory kind of activity
in fact when you wire people up when
they're reading more of their brain
lights up a lot more than when their
guess what watching TV because you have
to participate in the in the act of
creating the story it's I would say
reading is - to the spoken word as a
musical score with somebody playing it
is to the composition that you hear so
the page is really just a score for
voice and when you're reading that page
you the reader are the musician you're
doing the interpretation you're also
doing the costume designed the acting
you're doing all of those things so I'd
like to leave room for that and I'd like
to leave room for the reader to join in
the invention and sometimes I just can't
think of how
[Laughter]
yes why'd you consider your stories
engage with with the culture power or
let's say in the culture a culture of
American power given that you came out
of a Canadian background and in that
regard which of your stories do you
think feels the most Canadian to you
that's a double question how does my how
do I think my writing engages with the
issue of power specifically American
power by which I'd take it you mean
American power in the world
or possibly American power within
America number one and number two which
of my stories appeals most to Canadians
well there is a shocking piece of news
for you first of all not all Americans
are alike and the other thing that goes
along with that is not all Canadians are
alike so some of them like one thing
some like another they tended to be
quite keen on on the blind assassin
because it had a lot of history in it
that they recognized but similarly
similarly they liked counsel but so did
a lot of people it was a generational
thing the power question to get back to
that I think all narratives include an
element that has to do with with power
that is who's got the power in the story
who's got less power how does the crafty
person with last power go about fooling
the person with more power and so on and
so forth I don't know whether there's a
direct answer to your first question
because I'm not writing a directly small
P political kind of book that is I don't
write about the Republican Party and the
Democratic Party and those kinds of
things I think I write about about
attitudes and what those attitudes do
to people in relationships and when
they're transferred into big when
they're when they become large-scale
what kinds of effects they can have on
people in The Handmaid's Tale for
instance there's a powerful totalitarian
government in Oryx and Crake government
has more or less as we know it today
more or less vanish and security issues
are in the hands of mercenary armies
read any news lately
that's is making a lot of money in Iraq
at the moment their English mercenary
armies so that's as good an answer as I
can do and I'll do one more and then
we'll mind it the list is the list is
long because this was once part of what
was going to be my thesis topic in fact
I got almost through it before I
realized that I didn't have to take to
new University after all I can write
film scripts that never got made so yes
the 19th century ones in particular and
watch for it coming out soon my
introduction to the island of dr. Moreau
and on the stands even as we speak as my
introduction to rider Haggard's she so
that will tell you something about that
I'm not very current that is I'm not up
on absolutely everything that's being
done today but if you want to read my
review of Ursula Le Guin it was in the
New York Review of Books last year and
that hasn't somewhat of an overview you
know where did science fiction come from
etc
so all of the all of the classics
including some of the ones who have
never heard of such as wh Hudson and his
strange book a crystal age and the
purple cloud you know those those kinds
of books I was very keen as a child on
the lost world Arthur Conan Doyle's book
about discovering a plateau full of
dinosaurs I really loved that it's been
made into some really bad movies but I
liked it as a book so if you want the
full reading list we can talk but it's
it's long and one of the things I
probably got from doing all about as
some ideas on what I myself would like
to avoid you know because there
sometimes parts in them that you think
we might have been better off without
and on that note I will say thank you
very much you right audience
you